comment tu fais pour monter sur scène
qu'on a volé des vêtements dans les
zéniths sur un montage de doni
triqueneaux voici le making of du zénith
diva dans dix minutes
d'europort à se demander si on va
pouvoir maintenir un spectacle
non condom bravo à tous
il coiffe et la phrase l équipe comme ça
toi tu cinq minutes avant
cinq mille personnes
et à ce moment tu passes de tout seul
avec
tout le monde
c'est étrange
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
et avant de faire fort que tout est
normal de monter sur une scène devant
5000 personnes à toute la préparation de
la journée
et ça commence très tôt le matin
est déjà là venez créer avoir un truc au
loin vous voyez c'est le joli camions et
bien c'est notre camion de tournée les
rideaux sont tirés parce que alice d'or
c'est alice qui conduit le camion de
tournée et donc c'est la dernière fois
puisque bienvenue à la dernière au
zénith de paris
c'est une fourmilière on sent pas contre
le nombre de personnes que ça implique
d'essayer de rallier un seul spectacle
fait visiter sa fait la scène ce que
vous voyez derrière ces panneaux d'une
led tout ce que vous voyez là ça
n'existe pas dans une grande salle sans
vous le dit pas assez que tu loues une
salle il n'ya rien enfin il faut ramener
la scène le son la lumière le manger le
caméraman
pour on va voir la scène ronde sénégal
gros trac tout est proportionnel il ya
dix ans que des 49 places lors des ses
seins j'aimerais qu'il ya dix ans
c'était 49 places 49 places où on se
disait s'il ya vingt spectateurs c'est
super il ya réellement la moitié de la
salle qui rompit que la roue banque
commente trois secondes le big bang
comment
les conservateurs et voilà
comment dire bonjour à tout le monde ça
veut dire faire pas mal de kilomètres
essayez de trouver tout le monde monte
et descend des sandwiches etc et chic et
toi ça va moins ça va parce que je
retrouve toute mon équipe de tournée me
faire le repérage du génie qui a des
mois et des mois et j'avais la caméra de
blogs de machines secondaire et en
rigolant j'ai montré un siège et j'ai
dit est sous ce siège l'a d'ailleurs il
y aura une surprise
c'est ce que j'allais dire quand tout
ceci et cela remet un peu scotché
interdit soit la personne qui à ce siège
c'est qu'ils avaient la surprise s'en
souvient vérifie qu'elle trouve le truc
soit elle vérifie pas mais quelqu'un
d'autre a regardé le blog laissant des
souvenirs et viendra et vérifiera et
trouvera le cadeau soit personne s'en
souvient et personnes vérifient et on
retrouvera nous le cadeau à la fin et je
serais mort de rire de me dire qu'il ya
que moi qui avait retenu ce que j'avais
dit semarang
on va peut-être que la surprise est ce
ratio passe souvent ciel
je veux monter tout en haut pour voir
comment on voit les dernières
franchement on voit bien même du fond
sans décote ça c'est un truc que je fais
quasiment dans toutes les salles et ses
guides m'asseoir à tous les emplacements
possibles de la salle pour voir comment
vous vous allez voir le spectacle et les
deux écrans qui assure les côtés ce sera
des retours plan serré de ma gueule est
clairement un autre enjeu parce qu'on
capte le spectacle il ya une seule
captation il ya une seule représentation
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur et que la
perds ton temps je fais plus trop de
captation un peu sur ma faim
donc en général quand je fais des choses
sur les choses que j'aime bien
fabien j'aime bien son travail du coup
ça m'intéresse à vous faire ça en france
merci merci pour la confiance donc il
faut tout anticiper tout préparé pour
qu'au moment du spectacle les cadreurs
ne soient pas surpris de mes mouvements
meira
en fait tu regardes on dit une fois cinq
personnes je vais commencer par là où
vous avez assez participer
vais aller parmi vous si vous voulez
participer aller sur scène je prends
cinq personnes le vélum soir quel est
ton prénom mademoiselle on a deux
personnes ton prénom c'est quoi
et c'est pourquoi vous vous voyez rire
un peu n'importe où et c'est pas
vraiment n'importe quoi aussi pour
garder après la version définitive du
spectacle d'ombrés que repasser par les
mêmes escaliers 32 sanaa peu près dans
les mêmes zones que celle que j'ai
indiqué au réalisateur au départ
et pendant ce temps là on compte l'écran
montrent la lumière diablo que les
marques au sol encore une fois c'est de
se dire est ce que on a tous bien
orchestrée pour avoir la meilleure
musique de spectacle possible
[Musique]
c'est
là il est 15h30 en vie d'apprendre qu'on
a perdu les trois tee-shirts qu'on a
dans le monde pour la tournée
par ce matin de plus en plus être partie
au pressing et depuis on ne retrouve
plus du sol et
donc c'est gênant puisque ce soir cette
limite et c'est surtout la captation du
spectacle donc ça c'est un peu le comble
qui n'est pas sa tenue de scène pour le
seul soir ou
me faire refaire les routes aubry à
chaque fois qu'ils en maths et comme
imprimer sur paris roubaix un tee shirt
cette histoire fait fichiers way la
photo de référence est celle on est tous
les deux c'est qu'en effet on a
comme ça et c'est à peu près les
proportions
à l'étude et nous traitant de
[Musique]
la jusqu'à sept rangs ouais la largeur
la première en janvier de mon spectacle
de création
parce que c'est ça la vie du spectacle
vivant un jour tu fais une salle de 5000
places et puis quelques semaines après
tu reprends un nouveau spectacle en
création et qui va repasser dans ses 60
places en vrai c'est 2 stress très fort
mais les deux n'ont rien à voir ils sont
pas comparables
jamais un chalet pas mal d'artistes déjà
déjà pas mal de holy dis bien un peu
flou sa force bien évidemment des
parlements des commandes et des élites
je vous ai pas pu la prendre en photo et
non politique
commence à être installé on voit le
magnifique plan de feu de la créa
lumière de diablo là maintenant il
s'agit de répéter prendre l'espace
vérifier que tout est en place aussi
pour moi et dans mon esprit et surtout
refaire tout le spectacle toutes les
étapes tous les mouvements les
changements de lumière les changements
ne sont que tout le monde soit raccord
et qu'encore une fois les cadreurs et
les réalisateurs sache tout en avance
sur terre il affronte commence à me dire
des deux il complète des mâles de 5
à 6
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euros
merci dans l'une beaucoup thomas grand
monde sur terre elle valait de les poser
à la cour
on se retrouve avec un
un procédé diffusion complètement
différent c'est à dire que d'habitude on
est sur une date la vidéo projection et
on se retrouve avec un mur de l'aide
qu'on se retrouve avec des écrans en
plus sur les côtés ils vont au niveau
scénique ont à peu près dans la même
chose une scène plus grande finesse et
un procédé diffusion sonore aussi un peu
différent et adapté on est plutôt dans
le timing qu'on s'était fixés donc ça
c'est cool bien sûr il ya toujours un
peu de retard mais on est plutôt pas mal
sur le timing on est pressé du spectacle
vivant donc on improvise on improvise en
permanence en fait taire quand on
travaille en amont 6 mois al avance sur
des dates comme celle ci et le tout
c'est qu'on fait des fers en fait le
spectacle c'est ça s'est super bien
préparés en amont pour arriver constater
que or rien ne va comme prévu et trouver
des solutions
saas et jeff qui m'a envoyé la photo de
son premier zénith à lui je vais pas
d'accord c'était son premier zénith et
du coup c'était mon premier zénith aussi
parce qu'il m'avait pris en première
partie c'était son spectacle en entier
c'était incroyable parce que nous on a
commencé avec des formes et des cabarets
dans paris des petits gabarits il
faisait des trucs pour les mecs qui
venaient faire un salon du bâtiment à
paris pour moi c est du coup il ya
quelques années a commencé à faire des
émules et la plaignante était kiki comme
on dit qu'il envoie ça
[Musique]
à gauche
et l'arrivée du public le plus exigeant
mes parents est un peu irréel moi
j'irais bien on est très fiers de lui on
est fier de tous nos enfants mais
ce qui fait c'est quand même particulier
il a bossé pour faire en arriver là
comment il en parlait de la scène quand
il était cultivé en la scène où il a
toujours fait de la scène ici c'est
toujours puisqu'il faisait du théâtre du
petit coeur des 30 buts oui on a
toujours fait ce spectacle dans la
famille était réunie on en avait un
petit peu marre amène à lire et quand
ils vous annoncer qu'on réalise pas
continuer d'y chanter
je suis au spectacle devant lui
je suis très impressionné avant très
stressée quettehou et mais quand ça
comment je suis au spectacle voilà donc
c'est après que je réalise à battre
c'est mon gamin en vrai nom qui sont pas
exigeants ils sont un peu impressionné
je crois de ce qu'on organise peut-être
ça me fera bizarre vraiment quand je
serai assis dans la salle du coup comme
on l'a reportée plusieurs fois j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait ça suivra jamais
alors que je suis au zénith époux j'ai
pas l'impression je réalise trouve que
ça va enfin se faire mais je pense que
oui c'est vrai c'est un peu énervant
quand je serai assis dans la salle tout
ces gens là nouveau portable est invité
sur scène le parlement tout cela a bien
pleins ébats ça va la place a trahi sa
famille mais quels seraient ces perles
et puis surtout la concrétiser ce qu'il
voulait faire pour aller faire un zénith
le faire tu aimes produits mentale dans
un zénith
j'imagine que c'est inné
[Musique]
200 dates le matériel et fatigue un peu
il ya une vraie question qui se pose
c'est est ce que comprend du matériel
neuf pour le zénith parce que c'est
capté par ses 8 et qu'on veut que tout
soit beau et j'ai tranché il ya quinze
jours la réponse est non mais j'espère
qu'en changeant quelque chose c'est sur
le meilleur moyen de se planter parce
que c'est du nouveau matos parce que y'a
un truc qui marche pas et on ne l'a pas
détecté alors que c'est des trucs ont
servi au moins sur 50 représentations je
sais qu'il ya pas de problème je me
méfie toujours de cette une date
spéciale il faut changer des choses
auxquelles je crois plus en inverse de
c'est une date spéciale ne changeront
rien
le final du spectacle
je prépare toujours mais c'était
peut-être là on va le préparer dernier
numéro au premier numéro je ne sais pas
pourquoi
je le fais pas dans la
vraie réponse garelli c'est la magie on
m'a dit je t'ai mis la magie à gauche il
s'est passé pas de la magic
divisionnisme c'est la magie du
spectacle pour lui aller dans cette voie
attendant je trouve ça très l'union
comment comment ils appellent ça car il
le connaît depuis l'âge de 17 ans le
gars a fait 22 ans qu'on se connaît et
toute mon équipe comme ça on a des liens
qui sont très forts et qui permettent de
vie de nos membres
si vous voulez tout savoir ce que je
suis en train de lire la décrire juste
avant de monter sur scène je suis pas
sûr de le lire sur scène c'est un petit
challenge que je me suis demain
[Musique]
derrière mes projets il avait soufflé
derrière moi depuis dix ans comme un
vent violent
et le projet secret de ce sport personne
ou plein soho viable mais encore elle
sait pas tout
il sait juste qu'il doit mettre une
lumière avant de ses choix de manière
peut-être aussi reprendre ton équipe il
a fait le spectacle 200 fois avec toi
est là depuis dix ans et ce soir devant
vous c'est le mois 2 quand j'avais 10
ans
qui vous dit merci d'avoir donné du sens
et pas vraiment en revue ces images même
qu'on a monté la vidéo complète pour la
télévision c'est le moment que j'ai pas
voulu voir de peur de le couper
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref allez voir
donc je serai comme ça je pense la
plupart du temps voilà c'était m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez alex mettre les flyers sur
les sièges alex qui s'occupe du
merchandising
la photographe qui a une c'est laura
banny qui regarde son téléphone pour
voir si tout se passe bien ça veut dire
que le spectacle commence dangereusement
arriver
les zooms ça marche bien
alors du coup ça se finit que j'ai fait
un aller retour pour voir les parties
avait pas c'est alors au cas où ya un
mais
l'impression est un peu moche mais de
loin on voit rien donc au pire yassa et
signé du coup on a envoyé nos petits
espions en faire un thème et à damparis
je suis allé mais d où ils ont fait
imprimer la halle et je crois que la
personne en charge de sa est en train de
bien d'autres y aura un t-shirt 9 et un
tee-shirt ancien un peu moins on verra
ça c'est pas le bon boulot qui ont fait
imprimer je pense que fabien préfère la
jouer avec eux de d'habitude même si
ça restera quand même le souvenir le
plus marquant de cette représentation à
la dernière se faire voler ses vêtements
de scène vous êtes en train de voir
l'entrée du génie que moi j'ai jamais
vue du coup ce que tu passer par
l'arrière et c'est en repartant je me
suis dit mais j'ai même pas vu haru
arrive le public comment ils vont vivre
l'entrée dans les élites je l'aurais
redécouvert avec vous dans cette vidéo
et surtout nous on avait prévu de choses
pour les gens qui arrivent même avec
deux heures d'avancé des choses
interactive dans l'écran qu'on avait
préparé avec louis qui est denis
quelques semaines avant à peine on
voulait qu'ils aient une vraie
expérience interactive dès le départ
et ben moi j'ai rencontré fabien chez
franchement je ya très très longtemps et
je pense même que c'était sur une scène
savez de théâtre de dix heures à peu
près par la revue fabien partir de de la
comédie et remonte pour ce soir à trois
zénith c'est un truc de malade c'est
hyper émouvant ça hyper toujours c'est
drôle de voir comment il a évolué et
comment elle a bondi de le voir en fait
faire les étapes et de voir évoluer et
aussi d'être aussi fidèle d'abord en
amitié ça c'est sûr et puis aussi
professionnellement enfin moi je sais
que le fait qu'il ait pensé à moi pour
faire cette première partie je sais que
c'est d'abord un truc aussi d'amitié
mais aussi parce que je sais qu'il
écoute mon podcast et c'est ce que je
fais je me suis donc
cesser ces jolies moi je trouve ça joli
en fait d'être là ce soir et là te
retrouver sur la même scène ensemble
c'était l'occasion de se dire waouh on
en a fait des trucs en dix ans
et sans vraiment se le dire avec des
mots
[Musique]
il m'en veut pas sa photo louis bailly
dès le moment qu'on redoutait tous mais
qu'on a
c'est le moment ghost direction parce
que dans les vidéos d'écran avec loïc on
a fait semblant de prendre en photo le
public et on avait prévu qu'on prenne
réellement une photo en public à ce
moment là et je le poste instantanément
sur instagram mission à contenir comment
s'est rajouté des moments de pression
juste avant le spectacle parce que oui
le spectacle va commencer marine est
prête à monter sur scène
juste
on avait écrit que c'est vrai qu'on perd
on fait le point
[Applaudissements]
m
y être attaqué en disant ça sert à quoi
bon jouer l'un après l'autre devant 500
personnes ce soir vous êtes 100 fois
plus lorsque yard éléments et on sait
pas ce que ça veut dire 100 fois plus
que 50 ans on va découvrir ça fait
trembler s'il vous plaît les minimes on
arrête pas aux gens
vous voulez une fac ce qu'elle fait sur
scène ce soir là le fait pour la
première fois elle vient juste de
l'écran
tandis qu'à son sens bien
mais si vous comptez
faire la première de son nouveau
spectacle en première partie du zénith
de paris je trouve ça tellement steve et
sa part tellement courageux
qu en pense quoi c'est du times
pendant ce temps là je suis en loge et
la pression
[Musique]
c'est bon mais la musique qui te vendent
en attaque massive interdit ça te va ne
pas déraper un sens
je viens chercher facilement
jeu
d'habitude quand gary bien équipé quand
diablo vient me checker c'est vraiment
le moment ans marc fait les plus grosses
blagues on est vraiment des gamins là je
me rends compte à quel point on n'a pas
rigolé sans ces quelques minutes avant
je sais pas si c'est de la pression de
la concentration j'ai envie de bien
faire
il ya encore un espèce de non-dits assez
marrant de voir quelque chose d'aussi
sérieux alors que ça devrait être une
fête dans le fond dit un peu de
tristesse parce que c'est aussi la
dernière du spectacle
[Musique]
les dernières c'est toujours des fêtes
christ
la dernière c'est bien parce que c'est
le début de quelque chose d'autre et en
même temps on va dire adieu à plein de
souvenirs ans dit est ce qu on les a
assez bien vécu si la réponse est je
sais pas et il est temps les vivres
bonne fois pour toutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le singulier je crois que c'est ça
l'unité séminaire saint dié lumière
toutes et tous
beaucoup s'en aller
mais bénéficie sur cette antenne 2
alors que j'avais pu choisir les
spectacles vivants en finale qui le
place au spectacle
avec vous
[Musique]
deux ans de tournée qui se sont
transformés en trois ans avec le co vide
plus de 2 euros port de deux heures de
spectacle et bien le moment où c'est
enfin la fin
[Applaudissements]
je vais me reprendre et sur scène c'est
pas un truc qui était prévu c'est
vraiment méchante
toutes ces pressions qui avait accumulé
avant
relâche à ce moment là
messieurs je vous aime défendu hier
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Applaudissements]
there de près
deux heures pour ne pas faire plus
surtout parce que je suis vite capable
sur un moment comme ça de faire trois
heures
bravo
[Musique]
dormi
il
[Musique]
ces bons moments
et l'après spectacle quand il revoit
enfin les gens que tu aimes et qui était
là
[Musique]
mais tu m'as vibe
vous avez été la première à la dernière
raison
[Musique]
on est quand même plus détendu que
lorsqu'on équiper les micros
[Musique]
la suite on la pas fine mais parce que
c'était pas du spectacle c'était de la
vraie vie et puis c'était l'occasion de
se retrouver une dernière fois pour dire
au revoir à ce spectacle est pour déjà
penser à la suite
je n'ai jamais vraiment saisi pourquoi
c'était un avion le logo du zénith et
une fois que d'aller sur scène là bas
devant 5000 personnes à la toute fin
lors des derniers applaudissements bah
tu comprends
[Musique]
voilà grâce à vous singularité ça a été
double ticket d'or ça c'est fou ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup de spectateurs quand
même on aura fait toute cette aventure
ensemble c'était vraiment génial
n'oubliez pas la nouvelle aventure elle
commence maintenant ces archétypes vous
avez vu le teaser tout à l'heure la ja
la fiche ça commence au palais des
glaces à poursuit en tournée là il ya
déjà 100 représentations si vous êtes
inscrits aux mails aussi qu'il ya dans
la description vous savez c'est moi qui
vous préviendrai quand je viendrai dans
votre région si vous avez la moindre
question concernant le spectacle ou dans
cet univers là vous me posez les
questions dans les commentaires pensez à
vous abonner il ya du mentalisme qui va
revenir sur la chaîne prenez soin de
vous à très bientôt